أنا هنا لأعلن الانتهاء من
انسحابنا من أفغانستان في
نهاية المهمة العسكرية لإجلاء
المواطنين الأمريكيين
رعايا الدول الثالثة والأفغان المستضعفين
، آخر طائرة من طراز C-17 أقلعت من
مطار حمد كرزاي الدولي في
30 أغسطس بعد ظهر اليوم الساعة 3 29  مساءً
بتوقيت الساحل الشرقي وآخر طائرة مأهولة
تقوم الآن بإخلاء المجال الجوي فوق
أفغانستان ،
سننشر قريبًا صورة لآخر
طائرة من طراز C-17 تغادر أفغانستان مع
اللواء كريس دوناهو
والسفير الأمريكي في أفغانستان روس ويلسون
على متنها
بينما
يكتمل الإخلاء العسكري  تستمر البعثة الدبلوماسية
لضمان المزيد من المواطنين
والأفغان المؤهلين الذين يرغبون في المغادرة
وأنا أعلم أنك سمعت وأعلم أنك ستسمع
المزيد عن ذلك من
وزارة الخارجية قريبًا ،
فإن انسحاب الليلة يعني
نهاية الجيش.  عنصر
الإجلاء ولكن أيضًا نهاية
المهمة التي استمرت 20 عامًا تقريبًا والتي بدأت في
أفغانستان باختصار  بعد 11 سبتمبر
2001.
إنها مهمة أوصلت أسامة بن
لادن إلى نهاية عادلة جنبًا إلى جنب مع العديد من
المتآمرين معه في القاعدة
ولم تكن مهمة رخيصة
التكلفة كانت 2461 من أفراد الخدمة
والمدنيين الأمريكيين قتلوا و  أكثر من
20000 أصيبوا بجروح محزنة
بينهم 13 جنديًا أمريكيًا قُتلوا
الأسبوع الماضي على يد انتحاري تابع لداعش ،
نحن نكرم تضحياتهم اليوم ونحن
نتذكر إنجازاتهم البطولية